[Musique]
bonjour merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 politique
sur tv 78 et ce mois ci nous parlerons à
des républicains quel avenir pour le
parti dans les yvelines notamment
éléments de réponse avec pierre bédier
le président du conseil départemental
elle lui qui a adhéré au rpr en 1970
reste confiant et puis la prochaine
élection de revers que rapproche les
européennes scrutin en 2019 et déjà la
république en marche se prépare le
mouvement présidentiel lance sa campagne
invite et shahinez taleb la référente
yvelinoise c'est donc avec vous que nous
débutons cette édition alors que jeudi
22 mars au soir vous avez lancé la
grande marche pour l'europe
c'était à saint germain en laye en
présence des députés locaux du sénateur
également et puis du député européen
jean marie cavada
pourquoi lancer dès à présent cette
campagne européenne
alors il faut savoir que la grande
marche officielle
démarre samedi 24 mars le lancement
officiel au niveau national c'est ce 24
mars
on a trois points 3 prendre rendez-vous
au niveau du département des yvelines
alors le premier c'est à la salle du jeu
de paume à versailles
le deuxième c'est au musée du parc de
marly-le-roi lucian et enfin le dernier
à la maison jean monnet à bazoches alors
pourquoi annoncer cette opération
justement cette grande marche pour
l'europe
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que c'est une
grande opération de porte à porte qui a
lieu partout en france qui va démarrer
donc le 24 mars et va s'étendre pendant
six semaines
l'objectif c'est vraiment d'aller à la
rencontre des françaises et des français
pour recueillir leurs attentes et leurs
préoccupations vis-à-vis de l'europe
donc on le décline ce qui avait été fait
pendant la campagne présidentielle
exactement en fait c'est là l'opération
miroir de la grande marche qui a eu lieu
à l'été 2016 et l'objectif aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment d'euros fondé l'europe
paraît avec les français justement en
n'allant poser un véritable débat
démocratique de fond sur qu'est ce qui
marche
qu'est ce qui ne marche pas et qu'elles
devraient être les priorités pour
l'europe
l'objectif vraiment c'est une pas il ne
s'agit pas en fait d'organiser un énième
débat institutionnel
on est vraiment au coeur de notre adn de
notre mouvement en allant à l'écouté des
préoccupations quotidiennes des
françaises et des français parce qu'à la
république en marche nous sommes
convaincus que l'europe détient une part
des réponses à leurs préoccupations que
ce soit en matière d'environnement en
matière d'économie en matière de
sécurité en matière de numérique
vraiment l'europe a une part de solution
à nous apporter au niveau national
vous êtes convaincu les citoyens un
petit peu moins le scrutin européen est
en général pas celui qui a le plus de
succès donc il va aussi falloir
convaincre les électeurs et les
électrices
alors contrairement à d'autres partis
qui ont une démarche vraiment ambigu
vis-à-vis de l'europe nous à la
république en marche
nous sommes profondément convaincus que
c'est par la refondation du projet
européen que nous allons justement
pouvoir sortir et ferrer
j'ai une nouvelle europe une europe qui
va répondre beaucoup plus aux
préoccupations quotidiennes des français
et des françaises est d'ailleurs sur le
département des yvelines
l'europe est présente au quotidien
clairement avec un exemple concret que
je vais vous donner l'europe est engagée
avec le conseil départemental dans la
lutte contre la pauvreté et pour
promouvoir l'inclusion donc l'europe
travaille avec le avec le département
des yvelines justement à hauteur d'un
fond ce et social européen de 18
millions d'euros jusqu'à 2020 pour
justement faire en sorte de lutter
contre la pauvreté au niveau du
département
donc concrètement l'europe existe au
quotidien autour de chez nous et
justement l'objectif d'aller faire du
porte à porte et de d'échangés au sujet
des préoccupations des françaises et des
français quant aux attentes vis-à-vis de
l'europe c'est vraiment la grande marche
pour l'europe c'est pourquoi nous allons
mettre en place cette opération des 24
heures il ya aussi de la pédagogie se
sera pas uniquement pour recueillir des
propositions ce sera aussi pour
expliquer ce que fait l'europe et vous
voulez mettre en avant des exemples
concrets comme vous venez de de le faire
l'échéance est particulièrement
importante pour la république en marche
parce que la campagne présidentielle
aussi le message rayman mâcon du
président dorénavant s'est basé sur
l'europe c'est vous qui le dites en
europe fait partie de l'adn de la
république en marche exactement donc
l'échéance est particulièrement
importante autant sur la participation
que sur le résultat
exactement et en fait l'objectif
justement de cette grande marche pour
l'europe c'est de pouvoir aller écouter
sans juger l'objectif c'est vraiment une
pas rentrer dans la polémique n'est pas
d'essayer de convaincre c'est vraiment
d'écouter
qu'est ce que les françaises et les
français on vit pour l'europe
et justement à partir de cela nous avons
nous dresser un diagnostic de
de la situation de l'europe en france
pour les françaises et les français
l'objectif c'est vraiment de partir de
la base du terrain c'est vraiment ça
notre adn est un peu plus tard donc la
grande marche dure six mois suite à
cette grande marche nous allons mettre
en place ensuite dans un deuxième temps
des ateliers en caux intelligence
collective pour apporter des solutions
ensemble et pour construire
justement le programme européen que nous
porterons pour les élections européennes
quelle vision européenne vous défendez
au delà des propositions qui sont
remontés quelle est la vision européenne
aujourd'hui de la république en marche
la vision européenne c'est vraiment de
se dire que nous pensons véritablement
que nous devons réformer l'europe avec
ambition et exigence c'est à dire que
nous n'allons pas rentrer dans un débat
auquel nous pouvons assister
malheureusement aujourd'hui actuellement
qui est de se poser la question comme le
font certains partis extrêmes ou
populistes qui se nourrissent justement
de ce sentiment de défiance des citoyens
et qu'ils vont poser une question très
simple ils vont se dire voilà l'europe
c'est être vous c'est oui ou non à
l'europe et on voit très bien que ça ne
fonctionne pas que ça ne marche pas pour
la simple et bonne raison que
concrètement ça ne répond pas aux
préoccupations quotidiennes des
françaises et des français
et nous nous avons une autre démarche
qui est de se dire nous allons nous
intéresser à ce qui marche et ce qui ne
marche pas et quelle solution nous
pourrons concrètement apporter pour
améliorer le quotidien et on voit très
bien la situation d'incertitude dans
laquelle on est vis-à-vis du break si
tous voila il s'agit répondra oui ou non
à l'europe par une question et ça ne
marche pas donc on est vraiment dans une
autre démarche qui est vraiment de se
dire nous devons repartir de la base
nous avons aller à l'écouté des
françaises et des français pour savoir
ce qu'ils veulent pour l'europe
et si emmanuel macron veut se faire
entendre ensuite sur la scène
internationale aussi en europe mais au
delà il va falloir avoir de bons
résultats sur ces élections
est ce que vous sentez le couperet ou
pas pour être très clair alors pour être
très clair je sens le coup
vraiment très très près parce que
clairement vous l'avez dit hier nous
avons organisé une réunion de pré
lancement à saint germain en laye nous
étions plus de 300 plus de 300 réunis
dans la salle il y avait aussi bien des
adhérents la république en marche que
des personnes qui n'étaient pas du tout
adhérentes et qui vont participer avec
nous parce qu'ils se disent voilà
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe au niveau de
l'europe on a véritablement un sentiment
de distance un sentiment de roger et il
faut se souvenir pourquoi on a créé
l'europe quand ça a été créé c'était
vraiment pour faire en sorte qu'on ait
une entente que les peuples soient unis
et qu'on maintienne la paix et les
personnes sont très attachés à ça donc
hier il y avait énormément de femmes et
d'hommes qui n'étaient pas adhérents et
adhérentes à la république en marche et
qui vont venir avec nous faire du porte
à porte pendant ces six semaines donc je
suis extrêmement confiante quant à la
méthode que nous employons pour
justement aller convaincre un maximum
d'électeurs pour voter pour les
européennes 7 confiante sur l'issue du
scrutin scrutin qui change un petit peu
en aura l'occasion d'y revenir d'ici à
2019 mais dorénavant il ya 79 sièges à
pourvoir 5 de plus qu'en 2014
et puis dorénavant il ya une seule et
unique circonscription celle de la
france avant il y en avait plusieurs 1
laisse le sud-ouest le nord-ouest ou
encore l'île de france
là aussi il faut expliquer comment ça
marche ce scrutin c'est pas forcément
très facile et autres questions au
niveau des candidats comment ça va se
passer vous avez déjà des candidats
alors aujourd'hui clairement il n'y a
pas de candidat officiellement
investi et j'ai d'ailleurs je ne suis
pas dans les séries que pour avoir ces
informations
mais on aura une liste nationale et sont
en cours de réflexion est la première
brique que l'on pose nous aujourd'hui
c'est de se dire avant même de se dire
qu'ils seront les hommes et les femmes
qui vont porter notre projet c'est
qu'elle est notre projet et le caler
notre projet on va dire et on va y
répondre
grâce à cette grande marche qui est au
plus près de la réalité du terrain et
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose de
fondamental pour nous parce que c'est la
première pierre pour construire
justement notre projet européen de
refondation de l'europe et avec quelles
alliances au niveau européen alors où ce
que pour l'instant la république en mars
n'a pas d'alliance sur le sol de la
scène européenne aujourd'hui c'est en
cours de discussion je n'ai pas les
éléments en sa possession mais peut-être
dans plusieurs mois doit droite tantôt à
gauche dans les autres pays européens
quel tel positionnement
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas honnêtement ça
serait m'avancer alors que je n'ai pas
tous les éléments mais bien évidemment
ça restera des valeurs et des principes
qui sont proches de la république en
marche et bien évidemment le
progressisme au centre de tout
une dernière question on quitte la
question européenne emmanuel macron on
le dit présent sur de trop nombreux
fronts parfois avec le nombre de
réformes qui sont annoncés au quotidien
et on le voit maintenant en cette fin du
mois de mars
il ya plusieurs manifestations qui sont
annoncés est ce que pour vous mêmes
macron et sur trop de fronts à la fois
pas du tout je pense qu'il m'a eu et le
maquereau
fait ce qu'il dit et c'est important
c'est la première fois qu'un président
de la république met en place aussi
rapidement son programme l'objectif
c'est d'être en mesure de pouvoir d'ici
à la fin du quinquennat évalué qu'est ce
qui a marché qu'est ce qui n'a pas
marché et c'est important parce que
habituellement on a des présidents qui
sont élus qui et distillent leur
programme tout au long de leurs
quinquennat et dont on n'a pas le temps
de mesurer l'impact de leurs réformes
hélas aujourd'hui emmanuel macron silva
liszt et volontaire c'est justement pour
appliquer son programme et être en
mesure d'ici à la fin du quinquennat de
pouvoir évaluer et voir qu'est ce qui a
marché et qu'est-ce qui n'a pas marché
et c'est important parce que nous devons
cela aux françaises et aux français qui
nous ont fait confiance et qui ont élu
emmanuel macron président de la
république malgré la contestation dans
la rue et qui va pénaliser aussi qui va
paralyser une partie de la france dans
les prochaines semaines prochains mois
puisqu'on parle de grève ne serait ce
que dans les transports et sur les trois
prochains mois malgré la contestation
dans la rue c'est important en fait
quand on fait des réformes on ne peut
pas faire l'unanimité quand on a vite
changé des choses il ya tour ailleurs il
y aura toujours des personnes pour des
personnes contre ce qui est important et
c'est important qui est justement ce
débat dans la rue c'est vraiment que les
principes démocratiques puissent exister
et qu'on puisse faire entendre les
différentes opinions et qu'on puisse
justement se concerter parce
qu'aujourd'hui on voit très bien qu'on a
énormément de concertation avec les
membres du gouvernement et les
différentes parties prenantes et c'est
important de dire que le gouvernement
actuellement et le président de la
république sont à l'écouté des
préoccupations quotidiennes des
françaises et des français
merci à gaza
allen le responsable dans les yvelines
de la république en marche élections
européennes ce sera en 2010 9 du 23 au
26 mai et puis dès à présent votre
formation politique qui lance sa grande
marche merci à vous merci là dans le
reste de l'actualité politique de ce
mois ci le front national qui vient de
tenir son congrès qui annonce un
changement de nom le parti veut se
relancer après la déconvenue de
l'élection présidentielle de mathilde
andrew est la nouvelle responsable
départemental était l'invité de grégory
canal est dans une précédente édition de
notre journal quotidien écouter ça
dénote autant notre état d'esprit en ce
moment comme le font qu'on vous donnez
vraiment ce à ce parti c'est parti c'est
un parti de gouvernement donc un parti
qui a réfléchi sur la manière de se
structurer aussi bien au niveau sur les
questions européennes
oui ce moment il ya un grand travail de
rédaction des traités de réflexion sur
la diplomatie pour enfin construire
l'union des nations européennes dont on
est un an des élections européennes
voilà l'objectif évidemment et ce sera
un projet comportera dans un an et un
peut-être un peu moins parce qu'il a
quand même la campagne commencera
certainement plus tôt mais
et aussi voilà le but du jeu étant de
s'organiser sur le fond la forme le
fonctionnement donc je pense que changer
de nom était aussi une manière de faire
sauter ce verrou psychologique à des
comme dit marine le pen ya des gens qui
sont sincèrement rebutés par l'image
véhiculée par ce nom par l'historique de
ce parti le but du jeu est de montrer
qu'on nous sommes tout à fait en
capacité de les entendre et de les
accueillir parce que notre but du jeu
comme le nom l'indiqué on veut
rassembler tous ceux tous les amoureux
de la france où les amoureux de la
nation française et donc non je trouve
que c'est une bonne phase que nous
amorçons la en ce moment et puis juste
avant de nous rendre dans les locaux du
les nouveaux locaux du conseil
départemental des yvelines à guyancourt
un mot de l'actualité est social avec la
cgt qui entend durcir le ton le syndicat
prendra part où quelques 36 jours de
grève annoncée d'ici la fin du mois de
juin avec notamment la défense des
cheminots comme revendication philippe
martinez était dans les yvelines voici
quelques jours au micro de nicolas
landry nous avons mis l'accent sur le
besoin d'investissements et donc ce que
propose le gouvernement qui peut
paraître une somme importante
puisque ça tourne autour de semble-t-il
autour d'une trentaine de milliards
c'est ce qu'a investi tous les ans la
sncf donc il faut une que l'état mette
plus pour permettre que les trains
circulent via un deuxième chose
importante c'est de doubler les
capacités
du fret puisque le gouvernement n'en
parlent pas le fret c'est le transport
de marchandises
c'est écologique ça fait moins
d'embouteillages parce que ça permet de
mettre des marchandises sur les voies et
puis ça peut permettre de mieux utiliser
les voies parce que quand il n'y a que
des trains de voyageurs sur les voies
ça peut paraître insuffisant alors que
si on double avec des trains de
marchandises y compris de réouvrir ou
d'allonger des lignes je pense dans un
département comme celui ci où il reste
des industries et bien ça peut permettre
et le faire venir les salariés au boulot
est de faire venir les marchandises
nous avons nous avons rappelé aussi que
le statut n'était pas un problème pour
la sncf puisque c'est pas le statut qui
cause les retards les statuts qui
empêche les train de partir nous avons
aussi insisté sur le besoin d'embaucher
sncf
lorsque vous le savez notamment en
ile-de-france et une pénètre pénurie de
conducteurs
[Musique]
pour poursuivre ce 7,8 politique nous
sommes dans les nouveaux locaux du
conseil départemental des yvelines avec
son président pierre bédier bonjour tout
nouveaux locaux ici à guyancourt à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout d'abord
un mot peut-être pour le personnel les
salariés qui sont ici 753 de vos
collaborateurs travaillent dorénavant
ici ce sera un plus pour eux déjà je
pense oui en plus considérable il était
sur une demi douzaine de sites à
versailles qui étaient des bâtiments un
peu vétuste qui date est pour le mieux
des années 60 donc je pense que c'est
une modernisation plus que confortable
du cas j'ai fait le tour du bâtiment ce
matin c'est la première fois que je le
voyais en fonctionnement j'ai interrogé
chacun de ses collaborateurs et j'ai
entendu une critique sur des problèmes
de bruit mais pour le reste que de la
satisfaction mais ce sera un plus aussi
pour les finances du département
exactement puisque nous allons céder
l'ensemble des propriétés que nous
occupions à versailles et ça paiera
largement le déménagement le coût du
déménagement donc il ya un bénéfice
naturellement le département ne fait pas
de bénéfices donc cet argent gagné sera
réinvesti au service des yvelinois
vous avez visité ce bâtiment tout à
l'heure et puisqu'on ne peut pas manquer
c'est sur la devanture cette affiche
pour la défense du département vous
réaffirmez l'avenir et l'utilité de
chacun des départements et qui plus est
de celui d ib
si on investit
dans un bâtiment ultra moderne c'est
parce que nous croyons à l'avenir
département ce qu'on ne voit pas très
bien par qu'on peut les remplacer et
toujours facile de vouloir améliorer les
choses mais pour les améliorer
réellement
encore faut-il partir des réalités et la
réalité quelle est elle c'est que les
français sont très attachés à la commune
la commune c'est le socle de la société
politique et cette commune elle a besoin
d'être accompagné par les départements
c'est ce que les constituants il ya deux
siècles avait prévu le couple commune
département lors depuis on enrichit avec
les intercommunalités parce que les
communes ne peuvent pas tout faire tout
seul et donc les intercommunalités
mutualiser des services entre communes
on a inventé les régions aussi parce que
c'est vrai que les départements eux
mêmes ne peuvent pas tout faire mais
globalement ce couple communes
département et celui qui est le plus à
même de répondre à ce dont nos
concitoyens ont besoin c'est à dire des
réponses immédiates à leurs problèmes
que ce soit des problèmes sociaux des
poubelles d'éducation des problèmes de
voirie etc
et ce message vous l'avez passer auprès
du président est ce que vous pensez que
le président de la république nous a
entendus lors de son passage donc
département des yvelines
ecoutez jean je suis sûr c'est un homme
d'une grande courtoisie entendu ces
décisions nous le
diront je pense que président de la
république doit être en train de mesurer
que on peut par dessiner la france en
partant d'une feuille blanche
la france est une vieille histoire c'est
une géographie très contrainte et tout
ça ne date pas d'hier et si les
départements trouver leur place comme
elle ils ont trouvé leur place dans le
système institutionnel français
rappelez-vous déjà l'émotion quand on a
voulu supprimer les numéros maison les
plaques minéralogiques
il ya un vrai attachement département
est bien présent à appeler crealys alors
après moi je ne suis pas conservateur au
sens où je ne suis pas pour une
conservation à tout prix des
départements cet ajustement a fermé il
ya des ajustements je crois aux fusions
de départements comme je crois aux
fusions de communes
c'est à dire je pense que deux
collectivités peuvent à un moment donné
fusionner parce que elles vont gagner en
efficacité c'est ce qu'on veut faire
avec le département des hauts-de-seine
mais la structure département en tant
que tel c'est à dire la compétence que
le département exerce en complément des
communes ça je pense que c'est quelque
chose intouchable
vous avez ce message politique que vous
avez fait passer on va profiter de ces
quelques minutes encore pour parler
véritablement de politique peut-être un
peu plus politiciennes en tout cas
laurent wauquiez vous a nommé
responsable d'une audit pour
l'ile-de-france sur les fédérations à
des républicains ça va consister en quoi
ça va consister en rencontres en écoute
pour essayer de sélectionner
les meilleures équipes possibles pour
remettre en état
notre formation politique je pense que
notre formation politique est
indispensable au débat politique en
france
on ne peut pas avoir un parti au pouvoir
qui sera à la fois la droite et la
gauche alors que la droite et la gauche
doivent se modifier c'est une évidence
puisque les temps changent mais il faut
bien qu'ils aient une majorité et une
opposition une droite et une gauche
j'ajouterai qu'en marche c'est d'abord
des sociaux démocrates
emmanuel macron était ministre d'un
président socialiste donc qu'est ce que
c'est en marche en marche
ce sont des socialistes devenus
intelligents et compétents bien donc ça
nous trouble parce qu'on avait
l'habitude nous la droite d'avoir la
gauche la plus bête du monde
mais il était plus facile à critiquer
nous allons devoir changer notre façon
on fait notre façon de faire qui
consiste à être d'accord lorsqu'ils
prennent des décisions que nous aurions
prise et à les combattre
lorsqu'ils prennent de mauvaises
décisions lorsqu'il ne prennent pas de
décisions comme ce que fait l'actuel
président avec la réduction du déficit
public et donc ça va être une nouvelle
façon de faire cette nouvelle façon de
faire nécessite des adaptations avec de
nouvelles personnes de nouvelles équipes
et je vais essayé modestement ni le
france de proposer les nouvelles
personnes et ces nouvelles équipes à
laurent wauquiez qui est maintenant le
patron de notre formation politique
qu'il a été élu démocratiquement par un
grand nombre de militants et donc il
faut se ranger derrière ce pas trop et
définir avec lui une organisation c'est
ce que je m'efforce de faire une ligne
politique qui sera votée au mois
d'octobre et ceux qui ne se range pas
derrière cette ligne là et qui ont une
voix dissonante ils doivent quitter le
parti
alors entendons nous bien ça n'est pas
une caserne des républicains donc les
voix dissonantes
bien entendu chacun pense ce qu'il pense
et il s'agit pas de réinventer je ne
sais quel parti autoritaire mais lorsque
la ligne politique aura été tranché en
octobre ceux qui ne seront pas sur 7 ni
politique faut qu'ils soient conséquents
avec eux mêmes j'ai entendu monsieur
mariani monsieur thierry mariani que
j'aime bien dire il faut faire alliance
avec le front national bien on va avoir
si ce vote est ce que je crois pas
d'alliance avec le front national
monsieur mariani soit il dit je suis
d'accord mais soit ils obligés de partir
on n'a pas besoin de l'exclure si
d'ailleurs c'était le vote est l inverse
c'est moi qui partent il est c'est la
question que j'ai posée avec des experts
sur ce sujet mais mes jambes et très pas
le parti le parti décide une politique
est pas la mienne c'est à moi de partir
le plus gêné s'en va c'est un vieux
principes de courtoisie la plus
élémentaire
et puis une dernière question la suite
pour vous ce sera aussi la prise de la
tête de la fédération du département des
mines
oui tout ça relève du même principe
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire à
certains de vos confrères je me sens un
peu vintage ce que j'ai commencé ma vie
militante dans les années soixante dix
et jeux reviennent donc au siècle
suivant
c'est terrible de se dire des choses
comme ça mais avec toujours la même
énergie la même envie et surtout envie
de partager mon expérience avec de plus
jeunes élus on a la chance dans ce
département d'avoir des femmes des
hommes nouveaux maires nouveaux
conseillers départementaux nouveaux
conseillers jeunes ont de grandes
qualités de grand talent ils leur
manquent pour certains et c'est normal
de l'expérience c'est ce que je vais
essayer d'apporter donc dans ce
collectif voit ça vraiment comme un
collectif comme une belle aventure même
petite pointe d'accent vous entendez
peut-être vient du sud ouest et donc du
pays du rugby donc je crois beaucoup à
la force du collectif
en tout cas c'est ce que je m'efforcerai
de faire aussi bien avec la fédération
des yvelines que avec les fédérations 19
ans merci pierre bédier c'est ainsi que
nous on ferme ce 7,8 politique on se
retrouve en avril
[Musique]